hi
welcome back to another episode of big
big move yay
thank you for coming back to watch us um
today we have a special guest
and his name is chester c this beautiful
man here he is our
our first single male guest yes
the only one not snatched off the market
yeah how does it feel
uh yeah i'm kind of saying you're pretty
single oh yeah oh you're
already not single i'm single no i'm
single on face there a woman out there
that's what i always say when people ask
me if i'm dating someone i'm like i will
say no but there's always going to be
someone that's really going to get mad
when they hear that
i think i'm in a couple of open
relationships maybe oh okay okay
that's more interesting actually than
being able to talk about
[Laughter]
um for those of you who don't know
chester nikki why don't you introduce
chester is a talented musician making
his debut back to youtube after a
sabbatical
right yeah well like 20th sabbatical
yeah
yeah yeah um he used to post a lot of uh
hot pics with his shirt off so go back
on his instagram
a lot of shirtless pictures you're gonna
find when it
comes to because they don't even give me
a [ __ ] about that he's just picking that
up from him
he has channeled into my body just [ __ ]
talk you right now
i feel it steve is in the room but yeah
i know chester's like really good at
doing music and he just doesn't do it
and like
he just is like no i'm gonna keep my
talents to myself and not share them
with the world and i think that's
really [ __ ] up and selfish but at
least he's coming back um
and by the time this goes up you
actually will be back apparently
because i saw your announcement yeah no
yeah this thursday i'm gonna
i'm gonna swing for every thursday again
you sound exhausted
have you resigned yourself to this i'm
gonna uh
yeah [ __ ] it yeah yeah whatever man
thursday sure
no i want to it's just i just i don't
even trust me anymore it's
the kind of thing yeah like yeah i'm
back i think that's how a lot of
old school youtubers are like all the og
youtubers
this is always a conversation it's like
yeah um i'm gonna start uploading videos
again yeah
i think i might yeah next week i'm gonna
start uploading videos and then next
week i'm like yeah i'm just not i'm not
ready yet uh
i think i'm gonna get a couple of things
together and then like i'm going to
figure out a format that that really
works and then i'm going to already been
through the process for years so you're
like i know i'm not going to stick to it
and you've been traumatized there's a
lot of like
falling off the off the shelf and then
getting back up and
picking yourself back up and then the
algorithm [ __ ] you
and then you come back and then you get
demonetized and then
yeah i can't even get ads on my channel
i gave up bro
i mean i restarted my channel like 16
times i'm not being an og youtuber i'm
just a lazy sex [ __ ] to be honest with
you
so yeah this channel i think got
demonetized so you know yeah we don't
know
what do we say on here we just talk
about something like what [ __ ] google
ads don't matter with that
i'm gonna write an angry letter so today
we're gonna get to know chester
uh i've put together a bunch of
just in case his youtube doesn't take
off uh you can find him here
so i put together a bunch of questions
to ask chester and since he's our first
single male that we're having on the
show i've put or not
or not or there might be a very special
girl
or not i'm single okay okay cool and
this is great because jess is also
single now we have two single people
here and we can just bounce ideas and
[ __ ] off of them
no kiss no don't make them kiss thank
you thank you
can you put just in your next music
video i've always wanted to see just as
a video ho
i can tell you great if you have
twerking music
she's been going nuts you play piano and
she's twerking
i just heard do you like the [ __ ] song
as a man i liked ben shapiro's rendition
of it i haven't heard that
i'm joking i'm joking because he's
because he's such a you know
he's a nervous definitely never made a
woman come
ever i don't know some women are into
that um so the first question
into what whoa bench appearance oh i'm
not coming i was like not coming
who's not into that they're like tell me
some more facts
first question i'm going to ask you is
what i like to what we started asking
the guests just to find out if you're a
liar or not
for a thousand dollars a day would you
have a p
alarm clock which means every morning
you can set or every night you can set
an alarm clock
and say like seven to eight a.m whatever
you want whatever you want anytime you
want
anytime you want right and you get woken
up by this alarm clock because it is a
man peeing on you
but when you wake up and go to the
shower he stops peeing on you he
replaces your mattress
your bed sheets gives you new clothes
and leaves a thousand dollars on your on
your on your nightstand
a thousand dollars a day how long how
long as long as you can't perfect two
but you can't take a break or else he
disappears forever and it doesn't matter
where you are it's at home if you're in
a hotel if you have a girl over it
doesn't matter would you get pissed on
every day for a thousand dollars
he stops when you wake up and he's not
creepy he's just a really chill dude
just a little bit of pee three he's like
sixty something his age
look at alfred from like a butler from
the back she likes pissing on you just
he's just chill
i'm taking my time because you're like
to see if i'm a liar but like i you
shouldn't have prefaced it yeah but no
because
i'm sorry i mean there's an amount
for sure i would be okay with this 365
thousand dollars a year
yeah but tax-free because it's cash it's
just they wake up it's not worth it yeah
it's not worth it it's not worth it
you're right i'll give you a number
where i'll tell you what's working
what's the number what's the number
because we have a poo number two so does
that mean you realize your relative
income
is already close to that because why
would you who are you to turn down three
hundred and sixty-five thousand
podcasts thank you
i feel like i do pretty well that's true
that's true
well okay so this is a good way to
either weed out liars or rich guys
that's true you pass the test out you
gotta do like ten thousand a day or
something for
five i do it 1.8
yeah i don't know i i think it'd have to
be over yeah it's compounded
so i'm in okay i'm in i'm in
i think you should ask them different
questions let's move on
and i'm trying to be all right you're
not a liar you're not a liar i don't
want to peed on every morning
that's like wine but you know that thing
where
they talk about like after a certain
amount of money that you have it's like
yeah
the value of more money like it's not a
thousand dollars is like
putting a 20 on there is it putting on a
five dollar bill it's like yeah
[ __ ] it i don't want to be peed on for a
five dollar bill you're like
yeah that's what he's saying gina it's
like an investment you've got to say you
got to go higher
aim higher with the p2 you're going to
do it like a year for a year
invest your money and then you can tell
him like hey man like i thank you for
all your people i'm saying i could make
365
000 a different investment like it's
it's not a good investment this is just
waking up
but waking up with that the most return
on investment you do
literally zero yeah there are crazy
people out there who like preserve their
pee and drink it because they think of
some health benefit [ __ ] you do
you're getting paid for this
i believe you i'm really i was really
trying to like yeah be honest about it i
believe you
all right nikki you know what he went to
an island of pigs and
he just went to like this is the fire
festival no no no
i wish that would have been amazing he
he uh
built wells for people with no wells
like joe rogan
noels yeah he like traveled he doesn't
even work like he's look at his hair you
look like a very boy
oh yeah oh yeah if you if you're
listening audio only he has a ponytail
and like bracelets
because he creates on his fingers and
he's like i don't even need a thousand
dollars for you yeah
i don't need your piss money i get it i
feel like you're
too good for money i get it i feel like
you're the guy i would run into in peru
that like teaches me how to climb a
mountain and find myself
yeah you're the guy like a girl like
breaks up with her long time boyfriend
it was like super destructive and she
goes overseas and she has a vacation and
then you give her like the best sex
she's ever had
it's like a lovey pray moment
all you need is just like a shirt that's
like kind of open up here and you're
perfect i almost need a little bit of
chest hair that's amazing
i think he's a little more neurotic than
i had on this morning then really
chester
you're a little more neurotic than that
guy i think you're more neurotic
oh i thought he was like the chill one
no that was insane
i gotta re-watch that movie oh you know
what i was thinking of was the surf
uh what's his face oh the weather
outside is
[Applause]
um um he's very famous he's a clueless
uh paul rudd yes
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah look at god
yeah i had no idea yes i came out here
and i just
got rid of my watch i was like oh that's
so cool he's like well yeah because we
got phones now so
you sound like you're from london god i
love him because that was a good movie
all right all the snow let's get into
this uh let's get into these questions
all right i'm excited kind of
um you know what i wrote this question
down now i'm kind of upset because i had
no idea what you look like until you
walk in here okay
and the question was how would you feel
if you started balding tomorrow and it's
just
i use a full head of hair taking a while
for him to start balding
i mean i think you just rock it i think
you just go and you just do the bruce
wells thing right
yeah you should i see all those men who
just like have like one comb over three
strands like the homer simpsons and stop
attacking steve
you should do that thing you know where
they like shave the top of your head and
then they just
i think dietrich's doing oh dietrich did
do that i think
they shave the whole top of your head
and like glue it to pay down
oh it looks so good though yeah he wants
to do the hair transplant thing i mean
that's why he doesn't want to buzz it
off yet because he wants to take the
the yeah well he's actually he's done
the bosley shampoo and it doesn't work
for him no you need the implants
yeah so he's like you have to take a
patch from the back of your head
and then put it on the parts that don't
have hair but
gnarly dude you need to have like some
hair in order to grow the hair
so right so that's a healthy that's a
healthy way of approaching it you would
just shave it and just yeah i think you
just rock it
yeah go all right now i'm bald mm-hmm
okay because i know that
losing hair is a big thing for dudes
like that really that's like like not
having kids i didn't get that before
before steve i didn't know that it was
like a big thing because i think guys
are hot without hair like
i think something sexy um i also love
baseball caps
so like i said it wouldn't even really
matter
yeah well guys doesn't matter what your
hair looks like under there i have so
many friends
because you know because my just my age
group it's like so many friends actually
have hair transplants and
yeah yeah it's crazy and it looks great
yeah
yeah if only you can donate your hair to
them because i will once they
right okay holy crap that's a good head
of
hair
steve's blonde and then there's the
black patch
just one squash people i called the
chest
that's all i could afford a teenage
sinister girl
[Laughter]
so we're going to go through the
timeline of dating now right okay since
uh you're you're out there and you're
out and about
single or not single we don't know
you're out spreading your seed
breading your seed around oh my god um
now it's a visual i like to think that
he puts in his hand just spreads it out
that's not too far away from what
actually happened
i like to think he's just spreading it
spreading it all over on the lower backs
of women in los angeles
and other countries and other countries
in peru
uh okay so let's talk about
what i get into what is this show right
welcome welcome
you guys didn't warn him about anything
no she's like you want to be on a
podcast he's like yeah
that's cool good luck buddy what do you
like
that shows the kind of person you are
you just jump in we dig that we dig that
yeah
all right so in the beginning um how do
you feel about a girl asking you
on a date and what's the best way to
approach you
would you say for a date um
yeah i don't have any issues with
someone like asking me out on a date
this one
what's best for pro i don't think
there's i don't think it really matters
so much because
it's more of a confident thing right
right at least i'm thinking of it in the
reverse i know that for me
it i don't really think too much about
what i say to a girl
and i don't think it matters you correct
me if i'm wrong like it matters what you
say to me well i mean to a degree right
but i think it matters more how you say
yeah i agree
i think it's more how you say it because
like i
i steve did not ask me out like very
suavely i feel like he
he was i didn't even know we were going
on a date and then he
texted me i think he talked about this
in his episode and then he texted me at
the last second like right before he was
going to pick me up he's like oh by the
way i'm paying for everything you don't
have to spend a dime
and i was like okay i think that means
it's a date it's not very like we need
straight forward
well so has a girl ever picked you up i
want to know like if do you guys really
have does that even really happen to
guys
i'm trying not in recent time i don't i
don't have a memory of
going out on a date that was driven by
like her asking but um
yeah i don't know no i don't think so
how do you do it how is it
yeah what's so difficult yeah do you
approach women like in person
or do you do with dms or online dating
it's hard in the pandemic era
right right right yeah before the
pandemic before so
so here's my method oh god knock it down
so sometimes you go what you do is you
go on tinder right and you don't
try to match with anyone tinder you
don't worry about it don't try to
imagine that you just find out who you
think is attractive and they always show
their instagram
so then i go to the instagram and i just
slide in the dms no
what no yeah every i'd say like that
works yeah there's like a ten percent
return you got shotgun this right so you
do like you cast a wideband yeah cast
wide net like
of like 10 people and then like someone
gets back to you and then you talk you
connect
wait why don't you just match on tinder
though i just it's
because you it's easier to it really
matters like what platform you're
well i think you look it's worked for me
at least in terms of having like
if it works why fix it well yeah i guess
that works for like regular but like say
you have someone with a lot of followers
like their dm's are like
pretty [ __ ] full of just trash like
like
pretty much all of us so that wouldn't
really work on like some girls that's
true and maybe you're cutting yourself
short because
you don't realize you know how
how popular these women are
i'm just saying like that wouldn't work
on a lot of girls oh
yeah but it's a you know it's a shotgun
approach
why is it bird shot it's just everywhere
should i not say that i'm on sa as well
what what's that say
seeking arrangement oh can you can we
talk about that yeah we're going to talk
about that yeah [ __ ] the rest of the
questions
yeah seeking arrangements for those of
you who don't know
no are you seeking a cougar arrangement
are you the sugar baby yeah i'm looking
for a sugar mama
oh and amanda no i'm joking
you wouldn't take the pee but you're
gonna be sure you see
we accepted him immediately we're like
oh okay cool i make sure it's very clear
that we're not
doing escort right scenarios because
it's a very like there's a giant porsche
most of essay i think is that like it's
probably kind of that actually a lot of
people are making lots of dough doing
feet picks on
seeking arrangement yeah yeah also i
know people just meet up and i just want
like i've heard there's a lot of guys
that just want time with somebody like
oh yeah but i don't want to feel alone
there's a lot i think a lot of it really
is
wait so is this a joke are you really on
seeking arrangement
he plays a joke he plays the fifth as
well
attorney like i i have met people on
essay and it's been uh
there's no money exchange do i need to
sign up for this
so yeah i've met people so here's what i
learned mostly should i get on this tell
me well you're
i don't know i don't know how it works i
don't it's a different scenario for the
girl that is the guy
but um i've met with people where they
really are just interested in like
somebody that is going to take them to
actually like like a nice place and like
have like
like a high maintenance woman that's
like i don't don't [ __ ] coffee me
yeah and yes i think the
so part of the benefit from the guys
perspective it kind of like switches the
role so i
i can just like sit back and then go
through my messages i don't have to do
anything
because they're like assuming that maybe
you have money and you're more stable
yeah yeah that's on exactly these other
tender [ __ ] pursuits yeah oh that's
really interesting
just i'm gonna set up a profile for you
he's like who do i have to pee on and
give a thousand dollars to a day
i am the butler i am the peer right
i want to clear that there's no money
exchange so you're not
prostitutes you're not buying
prostitutes no i don't assume you have
money
right yeah okay well seeking
arrangements is like their whole thing
is like oh we're not a prostitute type
well there's this thing called ppm right
so it's a price per meeting that's like
the lingo
okay what the [ __ ] everything sounds
like stocks when he talks i don't know
is it compounded ppm i would buy things
god no i would never get involved with
that
um and so you know i think if you're up
front right away but
majority of the girls on there are
expecting some sort of ppm which means
that if they're going to meet up and
hang out that they
want to get paid for their time okay um
[ __ ] i'll set up the profile myself i
don't need a manager i just want to be
involved all right i want to be involved
in your life
are you going to come on these dates
with me yes i'm gonna fix my my hair and
makeup i will sit over there with the
mustache and newspaper and that will be
your muscle
she's gonna make sure you have really
dope head shots you're gonna be my
security then you can do it and i will
scope him from outside like
he's a lot shorter than he says he is
[Laughter]
as long as you know everyone knows that
there's no money exchange yeah
some girls on there they actually are
offended at the idea of a ppm like they
really do just want to meet up with
someone that is like more financially
stable yeah okay
yeah there really isn't that section of
this right that's me i want to meet up
with someone visually stable
yeah but this is for entertainment value
only
uh nobody is legally bound to any of the
statements they are making on this show
yeah absolutely wanted to give a shout
out to our sponsor skillshare
skillshare is awesome if you i love
learning
i think i'm addicted to learning like
anything i don't know about yet like any
stimulation like where i'm like i want
that that's a challenge let's do that we
have a lot of free time right now yeah
yeah and especially in the free time um
so skillshare is
a great resource for learning they have
so many different classes on all kinds
of different subjects
i took this one class called beyond
watercolor learned to paint with gouache
squash squash listen i'm just learning
okay i'm a beginner
it's a painting class on english class
we get it it was with leah gorin she's
wonderful
and um i like wanted to learn how to
watercolor was super relaxing like
just being in your room with the
candlelit and like a bob ross vibe
yeah some and i have like lo-fi uh
yeah beats playing in the background
while i'm listening to her and we just
like
make a soothing painting you know and
like you learn different techniques and
stuff it's great
um anyway i love it because uh
skillshare
offers membership with meaning with so
much to explore real projects to create
and the support of fellow creatives uh
it's also incredibly affordable
especially when compared to pricey
in-person classes and workshops an
annual subscription is less than ten
dollars a month
that's like that's like a dinner
right barely that's like one mcdonald's
meal
true explore your creativity and get two
free months of premium membership at
skillshare.com
big mood that's two whole months of
unlimited access to thousands of classes
for free well that's cool that's a lot
yeah that's a long time two months
yeah two whole months get started and
join today by heading to skillshare.com
big mood that's two free months of
unlimited access to thousands of classes
at skillshare.com big mood but what you
are legally bound to
is uh washing your hair every day have
you ever wanted beautiful
like chester healthy strong well boy
have i got something for you
and that's just his beard hair
i wonder if you could use function of
beauty on beard hair i feel like you
probably
can uh one size shampoo and conditioner
does not work forever
no the two in one only basic [ __ ] use
one size fits all
i've never met anyone that does that
with function of beauty you could take a
really quick quiz
uh tell them about your hair what
problems you have mine is my hair is
super bleached
um it's it's like really brittle and
falling out half the time because i
bleach it too much you guys are cheering
yeah to my bro bleached hair
that functional beauty fix so anyways i
get their purple shampoo it helps keep
keep my hair from being super yellow
because you know bleached hair turns
yellow yeah
and it really helps i let it kind of sit
in there for a few minutes and it helps
a lot do you get the purple one
yeah it's purple it's literally purple
shampoo yeah and then i get the
conditioner but i get it with no
um scent and stuff so i like that you
can you can customize it you would be a
no center
you know what you know what i can't
handle it function beauty has over 54
trillion possible ingredient
combinations to make sure your formula
is as unique
as you so what are you waiting for go to
functional beauty.com
big mood and take your four part hair
profile quiz and save
20 on your first order go to
functionalbeauty.com
big mood for how much twenty percent off
and let them know you heard about it
from our show that's
functionalbeauty.com
these bottles last forever too they lost
they they didn't lose their weight yeah
it lasted me the overage six months for
sure
okay now back to your dating life
is the quality of women better on on
seeking arrangements no comparison no
i mean like we get away from this topic
no because you know because since
there's no money no it's getting uh yeah
uh no i i i'm not by the way i just
cancelled my
uh my thing he's not even on it anymore
okay so don't try to
find him okay no it doesn't work i was
using it in my mind as like a
shortcut to go on like to go on a date
with somebody you know i
found attractive and whatever and why do
you have a pink nail does that mean
something
oh no a girl painted my nails the other
day and then i
i i kept one on oh there's no story
there
it's like yeah i actually they're all
white and then i had two pink ones
and uh when she asked me if uh if i was
okay with it i was like i think so
and then and then i was treating like
this insecurity test where i was like
will i have to bring this up every time
i see someone like my guy friends
do i have to explain why it's pink will
i be able to just like confidently
just move past it without and i failed
my guy friends know
you like i don't even think they'll ask
like half
half were like what's with your nails
bro yeah yeah and then the other was
like are you good whatever he's a
musician whatever yeah
like there's nothing wrong with that hey
hey i'm okay with my sexuality hey
it's called man polish okay god i think
being a musician too it's like it's less
nail polish nail polish oh nail polish
nail polish that's good don't feel that
it works we're trademarking that right
now
um yeah oh but you know i wanted to say
earlier
see the thing is the whole like not
messaging me and matching me on tinder
but messaging me on instagram instead
it's happened to me before and the first
thing that pops into my head is
if i wanted to talk to you i would have
matched you
but it works for different people though
so like these guys are obviously not my
type so i can kind of understand like it
would
work but how do you know that we if i
didn't try to match with you on
how do you know that you even saw me on
tinder i don't know i but also i'm a
little bit more guarded too because what
we do for a living and stuff like that
yeah but that's just the first thing
that pops into my head is like
if i didn't you know oh god if i was
trying to slip into your dms
yeah it'd be a different approach
because we probably have mutual friends
true that's true yeah we're not thinking
about it from like yeah think of
yourself as a pleb
a freaking peasant nobody all right i
don't know why
i can make it like that i'm not but
there is a difference right
of like how you interact with people
online because like this is our job
right so it's different from normal so
you're coming into but also
if a girl put her instagram handle in
her thing i feel like that's almost an
invitation
right yeah yeah i'm sure she gets to see
it like yeah yeah well i had to put it
so people don't know it's a catfish
yeah so it's like officially so you can
add them back and they know they're
actually talking to you right yeah right
um okay so next question what is
the worst date you've ever been on have
you had to shut down a date because it
was
terrible or have you
you know had to like you were about to
get it in and then you're like and then
something happened you're like oh
no have has anything ever shut deal
breakers
hmm sorry the first thing about my mind
was when i was
a lot younger my worst date like on my
end where i was making it real bad oh
well i just remember your own failures
my own yeah
i just remember i i it got so awkward i
just kept
asking like what's your favorite but it
got so much it got to the point where i
was like
so what's your um what's your favorite
number
oh my god and i could hear actually her
fault too no
i think she but i mean i should know not
to ask someone what their favorite
number is
you know like that yep yeah she's like a
million dollars that's my favorite
number i felt like i was in a sitcom
because i remember being like
she's like i don't really have um and i
was like oh my god mine's four
and i was like is it four yeah one's
four well now it's 37 it's changed the
[ __ ]
yeah oh you just want to prime them
like what's happening here there's no
common denominators that's what makes it
a prime number
so that's why he chose it i would think
that you would have chosen
oh 12 because aaron rodgers well that's
i mean that's
it's not funny we're on a fantasy
football team together but we both like
the packers and like
so aaron rodgers is someone that he
thinks i'm always going to try to draft
like super early in a draft which is a
stupid [ __ ] move because why would you
draft a quarterback that earlier not
even listening at this point
and i was being honest it pisses me off
you know what you can't you didn't do it
right
and that's not fair like by the way
where do you think four came from
brett favre yeah yeah oh well didn't
come from brett favre for me
it came because that was my dad's
favorite number okay
um see our date would have went so well
it looks so good i'll be like
you're gonna be like four like me too
this is going well she has favorite
numbers
well yeah so i guess it's like you
wouldn't have had chemistry with that
woman because the conversation sucks so
if you are a good conversationalist you
could turn anything into a good
conversation i feel like absolutely
so yeah that's her two i'm a good
conversationalist i feel both
it falls flat sometimes there's just no
chemistry
i feel like she just wasn't carrying the
conversation if you had to get to the
point where you get to ask what the hell
her favorite number was
maybe she picked a bad number too then
there wouldn't be anything
she's like an eight [ __ ]
that's disgusting she was so don't like
no like anything that was just like
okay red red flags during during dates
what are your red flags that you've
noticed throughout the years
oh when they're like super racist that's
a flag
they're just blatantly racist like see
that weight
mexicans
[Laughter]
i love like pretending i'm uh it's not
pretending
i'll do like asian accents but not let
anyone know that i'm half asian so that
they get awkward
yeah because i'm half filipino so why
would you why would you bait them with
you because
i have the half phil what kind of asian
accents are you doing though are you
doing easter are you doing it
look i don't know why that's the rule
but if you are half half of like
you get to just sort of i don't know if
there's a colonizer in your blood i
don't know if you should be doing it
it's true they say i'm white passing a
lot and i'm like you're not white
passing that is white power i'm white
basically you are not wipeout thank you
i'm like i'm everyone's ethnic friend in
mike yeah yeah yeah
yeah you don't like white passing to me
you look oppressed yeah i could only
dream
so red flags besides you know obvious
racism but is that a red flag really
like mental can you like mental illness
do you spot that
mental illness or like she's rude to a
waiter that's just oh that's a big one
yeah yeah yeah
huge turn off yeah um people still get
it or low tippers
well i would never know i i never said i
checked
i would never have the girl be paying
for it oh okay well that's nice um
i always offer half halfsies and if the
guy
is like no you can't i'm paying for
everything no i'm like okay cool that's
nice
i offered but he paid i always check
because
because i don't want it looks bad on me
because right
too and like if the waiter is like oh
that couple was a
piece of [ __ ] couple i'm like they took
me four dollars on a seventy five
dollars i see that [ __ ]
i leave cash on the table and i never
call that ross from friends do you
remember that episode anyone oh
the dad rachel's dad is yeah that's
right he's rich so right
yeah it's always the rich ones bro wait
but how do you check without you know
like how do you have to have laser eyes
and look across the table
yeah i look really yeah oh i'll oh look
i
think i'm uncomfortable too digits
across the table you can see digits like
oh that's like a four dollar
digit it's not like yeah dude if i was a
guy and i saw the girl that i took a
date on
put more money on the tip i would be so
embarrassed
yeah oh my god yeah and you know yeah i
wouldn't call you a dude back either
because
i mean what we've worked in customer
service before so we know
like don't be shitty and always tip well
and also like i
if maybe they didn't know sometimes i
get bitten for the doubt like 20
is like standard you know um but you
know for
receive uh he always tipped really well
on the dates on
restaurants and stuff but he didn't know
that you're supposed to tip
house cleaners um for like uh oh hotels
i know that for a while yeah
right so i didn't get mad at him for
that because you know if you
never saw anyone take a hotel so if
you're staying
like you grow up poor you used to
staying at motel eight yeah right you're
not gonna
think that's right but then now you're
older you have money and you're like
staying at the four seasons you're like
at least leave them at 20 or something
right yeah my mom and i stayed in a
motel once
when i was young and under our matches
because i thought you said a motel won
before the motel is way too fancy it was
just like
it was just a tent in the back of a
hilton hotel somewhere there was a hotel
gina
but we stayed at one and then we checked
under the mattress for some reason and
there was human teeth under there
human teeth bro like loose like four or
five teeth well a kid thought he was
gonna get some tooth fairy money no but
that idiot is under the people
i don't think you leave five teeth
behind for the teeth
that's something else going on and me
being a weird kid because when i was
little whenever i get my teeth inked i
want to keep it i wanted to keep that
teeth so bad
but they wouldn't let me oh you wanted
to keep a stranger's teeth i didn't i
thought
just because i like to keep my own teeth
i thought it was normal i like to just
look at it one time i found all my teeth
from the tooth fairy you know oh yeah
yeah she like yeah she stashed them in
this little thing i was like oh what a
pretty container and then i opened it it
was filled with teeth i was like oh god
they had like old blood on them
because my old teeth when i was a kid
god this is a really weird conversation
yeah i don't know
why um we used to yank it out right and
then there would be little cavities and
i would stick like toothpaste
and just play with it i don't know
after if a girl brought teeth to the
date that would be if she had a necklace
with media
yeah two minutes anymore yeah you guys
already guys already don't like these
it's usually like when you don't have an
id that might be an issue this one's a
little
can we just respond can we okay can you
say things that girls do in bed that
sucks because like sometimes we'll get
on here and be like yeah it sucks when a
guy does this like you know what he's
doing it
yeah like a girl's doing bed thing that
you're like well i mean the big one is
if you don't do anything
right right and that's like that's
actually pretty common like a dead fish
yeah
i've always wondered because you know i
don't sleep with girls and so i don't
know
what are they doing yeah they're just
kind of like
laying point hanging out and you're like
all right this is they're just like
you're just like their body is
literally not moving at all yeah a lot
of times not a lot but like
it's it's more common than i think and
then afterwards they're like he didn't
do it
hey come on now this is terrible i need
to know the extremities of the soap
is dead fish just like no you don't want
to do they also moan
that would be weird is she dead does
dead fish count as in like
she was on bottom the whole entire time
but she's still moaning and like yes and
thrashing about does that count as dead
fish or is this
out right no okay or does that fish
count as she never gets on top
what is it i don't think that that's
exactly i just think it's a complete
lack of like she's like not there
it's also the extreme but i look i think
sex is a very you know that's
however you like it is how you like it
so preferentially i have had the like
whoa
you're asking for a lot of work you know
i've had that
scenario too yeah right what's the most
like insane requests
oh i had i had someone ask me um uh
if if i was down to do like to taste
each other's blood
oh that's pretty hot [ __ ] weird wait
so you actually
should like cut you cut each other and i
was like during intercourse
i think i'd rather get on yeah yeah yeah
same let's get a thousand dollars from
that
there's a lot of [ __ ] in blood that's a
little scary you know yeah like
hiv it would have to be yeah yeah but if
you're engaging in sex i mean let's be
honest it's already kind of like
that's true the whole blood thing has to
be with someone that you've been with
for a while i'm not doing that [ __ ] on
the first date bro that's weird
like i'm not doing that ever yeah i
don't think i'm not i don't like blood
i'm a little queasy i don't even like
let steve
do anything during that time right what
could you be talking about
that time where there's blood pouring
out of my body yeah that's wrong you
should see a doctor
it lasts for a few days too i'm like
just doesn't even know what that is
just hemorrhaging for a while
um okay so so
what is it we moved past the first date
yeah his only turn off is
no teeth it's really easy
i'm really big on this i do not like it
if you bring extra teeth right to the
dinner table
i really want to pay for everything i
just don't bring teeth yeah
and then maybe don't just lay there when
we have something yeah she's like a
little movement
so i know you're alive yeah yeah she's
like you can wear a shark tooth from
peru but i can't bring my own teeth
double standard and all the snow bare
minimum
work um okay have you ever been sexually
harassed by a woman in public
because i know girls i just go up to
dudes and grab their ass yeah and stuff
like that
for sure yeah or like grab your junk how
do you feel about that when a chick just
comes up and grabs your junk
that's happened i have not that long ago
no i was like ah let me play with it
first
what that's the only thing i could think
of because i don't mind it but like at
least let me because i'm not a shower
you know like let me get
some blood going so you're talking about
in bed no i mean like in public just
like because i've seen some girls like
in nightclubs just like oh what's up and
just grab a dude's ass but if he were to
do that to her like it would
be really bad for sure but i mean i
understand that there's a difference in
like yeah
i get that and i definitely you know i
have a lot of gay friends and
i they they i don't care so it doesn't
actually it's not really an offense
but the action itself if you were to
just blanket it you know
just look at it as an action yeah
they're sexually assaulting me all the
time
constantly because i'm not asking for it
i'm not like i'm not exuding like i'm
okay with this i'm not doing any of that
like there's legal definitions for each
scenario yeah all right if you just yeah
yeah i am not offended however
at one point in my life i've never felt
like oh i really wish you didn't do that
it's just more like
that's interesting you didn't really
check to see if i was okay with i am
yeah i'm fine with i don't care but
you know right they're just so that
happens a lot more they're very assuming
yeah for all the ladies out there
because i'm sure someone's in the
comments gonna be like oh my god he's so
hot let's let's give him the good
let's give him the good [ __ ] um are you
into choking
yeah good good man good man we passed
that test
good man consensual what are your what
are your kinks
um i mean i like i like the the whole
tie-up thing that's fun
the bondage you tied her tied i do both
both
just suspended from the ceiling like 30
feet away from each other
should we just just wing a little rock
back and forth so sexy
[Laughter]
um yeah yeah the uh the straps and stuff
i think are fun okay
i like coffee swings costumes not for me
to wear but for her
right i mean i'll wear a guy's name but
i don't know what you want me to wear um
aquaman i think hamburglar yeah he's
going for it jason
yeah what kind of costumes we talk about
that you like
i think i just like short skirts i had
to be honest with you more than i do
yeah that or like it doesn't matter what
it'd be as long as it yeah
cool yeah all guys i think that all guys
yeah that's a pretty common yeah
yeah that's steve's number one request
is uh it's like
i'm going back to my dorm oh who are you
they like to see the butt cheeks fall
out of them yeah that's right
yes yeah with that little spot from the
leg to where it becomes a butt cheek
like your imagination has to take over a
little bit yeah it's like
tits on the other side yeah so yeah i
think cleavage like bottom
butt cleavage cleavage is there a word
for that there should be a better word
for
butt cleaves cleavage no we'll workshop
it yeah
think of it by the end hey listen if
you're cheap like i am and you want to
save money
uh there's a great extension on chrome
for this and it's called honey
oh my god they survived yeah yeah we all
shop online and we've all seen that
promo code field taunt us
at the checkout but thanks to honey
manually searching for coupon codes is a
thing of the past
honey is a free browser extension that
finds promo codes for you and
automatically applies to your cart
so when you're at your cart a honey
pop-up will come out and say hey do you
want us to scan some codes for you
and they scan a ton of codes all over
the internet in like a few seconds and
they apply the best one where you will
save the most money
i love it um so all you have to do is
wait a few seconds it scans this whole
entire database
and watch the prices drop uh i during
this pandemic
have been shopping a lot and i should
not be but i've also been saving a lot
so thank you honey
uh honey has found it's over 17 million
members over two billion dollars in
savings
if you don't already have honey you
could be straight up missing out on free
money again this is a free extension so
there's really no seriously sometimes i
save like twenty dollars like
for like a sixty dollar purchase i'm
like that's real that's happening
that just happened to me it happened to
me and you don't have to pay for
anything at all it's free so i don't
understand why anyone would ever not
put this on their chrome extensions
right um and by getting it you'll be
doing yourself a solid in supporting
this podcast
because we need to let them know that
we're awesome thank you
get honey for free at joinhoney.com mood
again that's
join honey dot com slash mood
i'm assuming girls like to pull your
hair i mean it's there
yeah yeah i don't know what is very
healthy and probably because you're
eating
so many healthy ingredients on a
day-to-day basis such as uh
the ones you would get in daily harvest
which is sponsoring our show today so
thank you daily harvest for
that i actually love daily harvest so
much so
whenever we get sponsored uh we get to
test the product make sure it's
something that we can stand behind
but then we only get it once like that's
it like we don't get to have it again
but i like daily harvest so much i just
keep paying for it like i
i love it so much freezer is full of it
my freezer is full of it and also i just
don't like going to the store like i
don't like going
i don't like leaving my house the
pandemic has been like hey you can't
leave your house my good i don't want to
so um right now daily harvest is helping
me beat the heat with their refreshing
smoothies and delicious scoops oh the
scoops are ice cream by the way
they're all dairy free good good ass
ice cream ass ice cream but ice cream
i am plant plant-based ice cream scoops
are free of additives preservatives and
fillers because they're made with whole
nourishing ingredients like black sesame
coconut cream
and dragon fruit and have four amazing
flavors i've tried all of them they're
all delicious
eating clean food with daily harvest is
easy and effortless whether you're
having it at night at home
or need a quick bite on the go i'm not
leaving my house ever but you know
it is good for that if you are a go out
there person
everything stays fresh in your freezer
until you're ready to enjoy it my
favorite thing is the broccoli and
cheese
cheese spelled with a z because it's
plant-based cheese and i really like it
it tastes like
normal cheese it's really really good i
don't know how else to express that i
like
daily harvest than to keep expressing it
to you but that's
broccoli and cheese mmm so good keep it
simple this summer with daily harvest go
to dailyharvest.com and enter promo code
big mood to get 25 off your first box
that's a huge discount yeah
that's promo code big mood for 25
off your first box at
dailyharvest.comdailyharvest.com
thank you harvest dot com
are you a vegan i am not fully vegan
i'm mostly plant-based but i'm i'm
dairy-free pescatarian
that's kind of what i am right now okay
yeah tight yeah i just joined that club
just recently
oh nice how long uh like
like a week not yeah well welcome to the
club i think it's the long hair i think
at a certain point
as a guy you have to get along you you
become a vegan you have to stop eating
bacon yeah
yeah it's uh i've i don't want to ever
go back i never have cravings
or anything i haven't had cravings this
week but yeah it's been a week so
the first year i admit um it was a
little hard but not because
i craved it it was because um when we're
out and about you don't realize how much
dairy and meat is in everything it's in
everything yeah and there weren't a lot
of options back then this was like four
years ago
what's the reasoning um originally i
watched a [ __ ] ton of animal torture
videos
yep and i was like i don't want to
participate anymore yeah so
it's funny because i okay so there i
think there's like two parts of it
hijacking conversation we're having a
nice date right now um
you already have a husband nikki yeah
i'm just sure you're married this is how
you get a husband okay anything right in
the middle which is
what you guys like make sure they're on
the same diet as you did you want to put
your order in before
yes do you have anything dairy-free
pescatarian uh yeah we we have the
just a piece of toast for you yeah yes
okay thank you i think there's dairy
free butter please
yeah yeah um but i think there's like
two parts to it so
i used to make this like joke kind of a
joke where the only real vegan is an
annoying vegan because if you're really
trying to like be a part of making
an impact on whether or not there's
going to be less animals tortured or
less
affected you taking yourself out of
participation
isn't going to actually change any of
the numbers however
then i and i used to say that i think
what i was doing was justifying
my own sort of gut feeling about my
participation and yeah well i'm not
gonna make a change
but then i used to do the same thing i
was like well it's already dead it's in
the grocery store
like it's just gonna die in vain then if
i don't eat it and and again if you just
because you stopped doing it
doesn't mean that you're going to save
even one life
but there is something about that
feeling that you have when you see those
torture videos
that you go this has nothing to do with
anyone else actually it's it's about me
aligning my own morals
that's exactly it and you're like that
it's too direct like you can play the
game where
you know sweatshops and you can do that
and and it's yeah and
you we probably should do more of that
and be mindful what we do but this one
is so direct right
it's like it's torture an animal and
then you're eating it and it's like a
living breathing
thing yeah and yeah exactly because i
never preached to anybody about it ever
i only tell people what they ask me like
is there any dietary restrictions
that's the only time i ever tell anyone
that i'm uh yeah dairy-free
pescatarian and in the fish came back
into the picture because of
like some blood tests i got back and i
was like maybe it's because i needed a
little healthy food
actually do you have that feeling i
didn't have that feeling about fish
because i didn't
the way they're treated well part of it
is like i'm a fish murderer
yeah no but fish
yeah but i really don't feel that way
with the pigs and the cows like they
know they're being tortured yeah but
they know
they do you know pigs have a
kindergartner
emotional intelligence level like
they're like a five-year-old you could
teach them how to read
and they know when their parents getting
taken away and they get very depressed
they've killed themselves kids or pigs
have committed suicide before
they ram their heads against the wall
until they die um so they they're in a
lot of
suffering and it feels like an evil that
we're turning our head to right
like a pretty yeah anyway and again
that's and again i'm not
i'm not i don't care what anyone else
does i'm just doing my own little
conquering myself thing like i know i'm
not trying to understand myself better i
just want to
take myself out so are you okay with the
like wild
food yeah you can hunt oh i i would feel
much better about that yeah i have some
friends up in northern california that
they kill their
sort of joe rogan yeah i think like they
kill an elk or a deer and they eat you
know
i have no problem with that at all
that's yeah that's that makes
much more sense to me
because i i don't i think that if you're
gonna do it like you should know how to
skin your own
like you should be okay with doing all
of that like taking the organs out and
all that stuff
i couldn't do it but i'm totally i don't
i don't care if anyone else does it
yeah and use every part yeah yeah oh you
know so far i was so surprised
yesterday i called my uh my sister and
my brother-in-law he's like a guy's guy
like construction management guy and
like
and always barbecues and uh mystery's
like you know he stopped eating meat you
know and he's like what
would you be you like yeah turn into a
hippie or something right
and then i talked to him he's like
actually i totally understand it and he
would that would say
yeah yeah he's not doing but he gets it
and i think most people are on that
like even people that eat meat and are
about like it's just so clear
i've noticed a huge change in the past
couple years uh actually like there's a
lot more options everywhere even fast
food chains have um beyond meat burger
or impossible burgers or whatever yeah
they have a lot of meatless options
whereas like
four years ago when i first started like
there was just no options at all just
pissed that there was no options like
i'm just
forced to eat animal products have you
had the uh beyond italian sausages
i love those i eat them every week i
mean the process is not the greatest
yeah
but they're you i don't know the
difference everything in moderation
yeah yeah i put them in my pasta hello
yeah that's so good
anyway david what's your favorite number
four well 37 now yeah
i have a question have you ever loved a
girl that didn't love you back
oh that's a great question of course
what is that
take us through that a little bit the
process on the male side because i feel
like a lot of girls
we feel like we're the only ones that go
through this unrequited love thing but
like guys go through it too
all the time one of that that's actually
one of the questions i wanted to ask you
was do you
i'm sure you do but just to clarify just
to ask it do you go through the same
things like
why isn't she calling me back does she
hate me should i hit her up what's wrong
with me have i
what's your emotional journey during
this like do you have because we feel
crazy
when we do that i was thinking more
about when i one of my breakups like i
was thinking about like
like when i was dating and i don't think
this is i think this is
sorry i'm just checking myself make sure
i'm not saying something i shouldn't so
tear
when tara and i broke up mm-hmm i didn't
return but um he was like
i wanted to stay together you know yeah
more so and so for me on my end it was
more like i had to go okay this
i've got to let this go somehow um but
that's i think that's different when
you're asking right because you're
asking
about in the initially is that what you
mean oh no i mean like either way in a
relationship or anything
so that was that's a good example yeah
for well for me
and maybe that sounds stupid but i i
wrote so many songs
and that were songs that did fairly well
for me too and as a musician and i kind
of turned her into a muse i think or
something you know yeah
all right i took that experience and
like channeled all of the my emotions
around i remember this era um yeah yeah
and so it's so you know i you know oddly
as a musician as an artist
those like very emotional moments i i
feel very fortunate that i have this
outlet where i can take that
that all those feelings and then kind of
release them
through art right um but uh but yeah
there's that
you know so you hate that that it makes
your best work i always hated that
like when i was doing stand-up i i felt
like i was only funny when i was so
[ __ ] depressed that i like had no
other purpose in life
like this was like my only thing uh but
then after i got happy i was like i
can't even write any jokes anymore
i think it's also too happy yeah too
happy i think it's also because people
don't
people don't really talk about like men
go through heartbreaks too sometimes men
just curl up and cry and they have you
know all those things that we all go
through too and
you don't really hear it often you know
while i
you know i again i'm checking myself i'm
so i'm in a men's group
right and a lot of my friends i think my
age a lot of them are actually in
some sort of men's group and it's wild
to me because
yeah we've been trained most guys i
think
or yeah you don't show your emotions you
don't talk about your emotions as much
but in these men's groups um it's a
really great place in the outlet where
guys can get together and just be really
open with one another and
how did you find this men's group i got
invited in and um
you know everything that we talk about
obviously is confidential and
you know but and the idea is that we're
always trying to raise each other
um and we check in with each other and
make sure we're being our best selves
but it's a place where you know maybe
someone's going through a divorce or
maybe someone's going through
you know breakup and it's a safe place
for someone to actually like
talk about that emotional event i feel
good so that like
because a lot of guys don't have that
then they turn to incels and they're on
reddit like right
talking about what's the extreme red
pill themselves you know
into hating women so having an outlet is
very healthy i think
yeah so i i i really recommend if
any guy listener i don't know uh yeah i
i think that's a very healthy
thing to have and our group is crazy
it's like guys that are in twenties guys
that are
sixty there's like a rabbi there's like
like insights that's cool all walks of
life yeah
like get a lot of different perspectives
yeah 100 that's true that's really cool
yeah yeah i feel like it's it's you and
you know
i wanted to know like do you ever get
sick of being
having to be the stoic manly man that
everyone's
kind of raised to be in in argentina
toxic masculinity masculinity yeah
the older i've gotten the more i've
realized it's sort of like this weird
like the one of the most unattractive
things
is when someone i'll say this way one of
the more attractive things and correct
me if i'm wrong
is just a guy being his true self like
just being confidently him he knows who
he is
and that's removed from this sort of
idea of needing to be a certain way or
masculine
and i think when you are concerned about
that you're actually
you're the idea of being more masculine
if you're trying to put it on
you can pick up on that turn off
yeah yeah sure i actually think that
more women like want some emotional
intelligence
like women are like why can't he just
open up to me a little bit you know i
feel like i hear that complaint more
in girls groups than i do like i wish
she was more manly
you know i am i've never met a man who
had to state that he was an alpha male
and actually believed him
i've never been using an alpha male
doesn't say he's not exactly yeah yeah
or like just i i personally love men who
are like
so secure with their sexuality that i'm
just like hey for a funny video can you
put on this dress they're like yeah [ __ ]
it let's do it you know like that is
peak manly for me and i just think it's
so awesome but if it's a dude that's
like
no that's [ __ ] gay i'm never gonna do
that it's just like you just made
yourself look so little i also have a
theory
about that what is it kenzian is kentian
scale is that what it's called
the scale well if you believe that you
know um sexuality is
on uh oh oh what is it she's nodding
yeah so let's say if you have gay bi
straight as a way to
yeah i don't know but um in my mind it's
like the guy that's
the guy that's like confident like very
straight and knows he's straight and
whatever
is not the person that's going to have
these sort of homophobic tendencies
someone that's maybe like questioning
and yeah and then we have a [ __ ] culture
that has made them feel
you know bad about that which is you
know horrific and
obvious it's great also because they say
like for a long time they're
perpetuating this idea that a guy cannot
be bi he's either gay if he likes a dick
at all he's
absolutely gay there's still that
they're like well no but i do like women
too so they don't want to like even let
anyone know at
all that they could be it possibly
interested in men right yeah right
never even heard that no term i've heard
the spectrum but i never knew it had a
name
yeah yeah that's cool yeah um okay those
are the ones yeah
because aren't they the ones always
committing the hate crimes and we find
out later yeah actually
yeah yeah like the law the uh
politicians or whatever they're like
trying to pass laws like against gay
people but then they
get caught with a gay dude in that back
alley somewhere
um so just to bring it back in the
dating thing really quick
so personally for me sometimes i don't
know how long
any of these stages are supposed to go
or what's what because things change all
the time throughout the years
what is the talking stage to you the
dating stage to you
um and then when you do want to make
this like an official thing do you ask
because i like to be asked because i'm
in [ __ ] high school apparently
i like to be asked right because i need
a definitive answer and like what's your
timeline kind of
so what let's start with what's your
talking stage
i don't know i feel like i'm in that
right now
ish what's this talking stage in a
dating stage for me i feel like a
talking stage
is like oh we went on a couple dates and
we're getting to know each other
qualifying
yeah yeah like you're looking for
preliminaries
yeah it's like interview one right and
there's still others out there
yeah you know i you know i've been
trying to be better at this just sort of
taking everything
really a lot more day by day in general
um and so i'm trying not to think too
much about the future of things
especially when it comes to
to like dating yeah it adds a lot of
pressure it does and you don't need to
like i had this moment where um in in a
breakup where it was when we were
couples therapy and we're trying to
figure out you know how to
like what was wrong with a relationship
and my therapist asked me this one
question that blew my mind
just one he was like can i ask you
something does it have to work out
and uh i was like whoa that doesn't you
know
and so we i think we ingrain this idea
that once you start a relationship it's
like
now we gotta make it work yeah yeah and
you're like well
invested a certain amount of time and
you know i have a hard time with that
too
even if it's just like a few months i'm
like well i already started this thing
but i want to have to go
back and like yeah first date yeah
right yeah i try to keep in mind that
yeah starting over is scary but it's
actually it's also really fun
yeah yeah all the dates you get to go on
the new people you get well when you
have an end goal in mind it's like you
want the perfect person not just like
the one that showed up first right yeah
i think there's a lot of managing
expectations
that uh that are involved in
relationships and so when you start
creating that like whoa
this is now that monogamous like thing
right it's like that
now you're putting these walls around a
relationship that you might not have to
yet you know so are you
are you at this point like more down for
open relationships
yeah like like i feel like i'm dating
right now right and so i
and it's nice it's and i'm not trying to
put too much weight on it you know i
i don't and i don't want to hold someone
back unless it's like
i mean i don't know until it's really
needed like well i don't know why i
would need
let's say you found the girl like you're
like oh everything clicks like
we have such a good time together like
we could hang out and be best friends
forever
uh i i love her i think she loves me
back
like i think it's reciprocated equally
um
would you be like i'm gonna put a ring
on it and how fast do you lock that [ __ ]
down
so i think the the ring thing
i do want kids and so i think there is a
completely different sort of mentality
around
a relationship that is driven by
thinking about that
yeah right but but but beyond that
like making a pact with someone all
right we're going to raise these
children
together and we're going to stick
together on this and that makes more
sense to say
all right the the cost of urges and
whatever is is part of this we're going
to we're going to work this out together
right
that's different um i forget what
there's a book my buddy just wrote me he
was telling me how like there was these
tribes before where
they had monogamous relationships but
they were
constantly just switching partners over
time like like they'll be together for a
few months and then
they would just kind of they fizzled out
that too and it was more natural and
is it like the village kind of raised
the children too like together i think
so i
yeah i shouldn't be referencing a book i
didn't even read it right but
the concept stood out to me when you saw
this was like the idea of it was
interesting to me where it's like yeah
you
probably could have a scenario where
he's like this works right now
and then and when it fizzles out it
fizzles out like no hard feelings it's
like it's it's
about personality type too though
because like with steve and i
uh like we're just both like well i'm in
this forever
like i don't even i don't see anybody
else as sexually attractive i don't
like care to ever have another guy
date me again or like another penis
inside of my body like i don't
i don't care at all like a pretty
healthy attachment i think yeah like and
he feels the same way like we're just
like we have so much fun together
and like we're just so he completes
every part that i like could ever
want or like yearn for that i i could
never see myself
doing an open thing like i don't even
want to like i don't
but also like i don't have kids yet like
i was talking about this on the will
smith jada entanglement episode
because you would ask like would you
ever be open to an open relationship and
i'm like i can't answer that right now
because
i don't think steve and i are the type
of people that would ever want that
but i also don't we've never been
married for 20 years or 30 years or
whatever we've never
had to deal like raise a family and like
maybe one person still has a libido and
the other person doesn't anymore and
like how do you deal with that situation
i've never we don't
dealt with that but yeah that's yeah
that's an interesting part to it i think
yeah
thing because i've had moments in my
life where my libido is insane
yeah and it has to be managed somehow
you know and and then you know i've had
moments where you know
anyway yeah what am i saying
relationships were i'm the one that
doesn't want sex and then i've had
relationships i'm the one that always
wants sex and they don't and like it's
there needs to be a balance or else it
really does feel like you're not
having all your needs met in a
relationship so i i don't know i
our relationship has never gone anywhere
close to that
point but will it in the future i i
don't know the libido thing is kind of
crazy i have a friend who's a
family attorney like a family divorce
attorney whatever and she said that
one of the main a lot of cases that she
gets
the man in a long a long marriage
cheats because the woman's libido
eventually you know
both of them eventually die down and
then the man decides to take
uh hgh i think it's like a testosterone
of some sort that you know it's
human growth hormone right and it makes
you like you know want to work out
because you know they start feeling bad
about like their hair loss they're like
they're getting fat or whatever so they
take that
and that drives their libido up and they
end up cheating on their wives hch
you lose your hair though but oh or you
know yeah body fat or something like
that that makes sense
yeah that makes sense i mean if i ever
get married my man wants to take that
[ __ ] i will kill him
there you go that's a good solution oh
yeah but my original my original
question
was like i i do you have a problem with
this
i never know when it's like are we like
officially dating now like do you want
to do this
exclusively or well i give her a pin
i'm just kidding it's like 1950
yeah we're not steady that's [ __ ]
good give me your letterman jacket
like here you go i got this i should i
should that's how i should
tell someone i would like for you to
wear my pin
pin that's a door i think if you'd give
me a pen i'd be pretty like
bashful and like i would make it like a
membership thing that's like a one year
one
like you're working at chili's yeah
i actually maybe recently i actually
proposed this to a few girls where i was
like what if we just dated for a month
they all said no by the way
in my mind i was like because we already
were kind of you know kind of having a
little bit of
a vibe right yeah and i was like what if
we just dove into
almost like an experiment it's like we
just dive right into boyfriends i feel
like that's the
the uh the opposite though of like you
know you're saying putting restrictions
on by being like we're monogamous
forever
this is like the opposite of like it's
like the restrictions of we can only
date for the short amount of time
i feel like that's also pressure it
probably is but i just wanted to try it
just like [ __ ] with you emotionally too
maybe it's only a month
you know you never know dude but you
know it's awesome i don't like that
yeah it takes a month to develop hard
feelings and then like you're cutting it
off
now because we've played house for a
month yeah pretended like you loved me
like a boyfriend for a month and then
now you're like oh well that that was
cool
that was cool at the end of the month
he's like we're going to have a monthly
review and we're going to go through
this and see how what we like
we might want to re-up we do it with
averages would you like to extend your
membership
well i just want to use code big mood
for
three months for three months off
wait wait it's probably a bad idea it's
probably best they all said now
when's your birthday january april april
uh
is that bad i don't know it's scary
makes sense aries are always trying to
move on to the next story i think i'm
more taurus
oh are you well it makes
it's all the same exactly whatever it's
all the same
all right guys that's all the time we
have today i wish we had more thank you
so much for being on chester
uh can't wait to see your new your
youtube channel get revamped and
maybe relaunched go check him out on
instagram what do you want to promote
huh instagram you got a new album
yeah well now that i'm starting the
youtube channel back up alongside it
will be
um my mission to 100 wells at the first
part
if you go to my doc my dot thirst
project dot
no sorry my dot thirst project four
slash mission 100
we'll put it in there yeah we'll put in
the description that would be the thing
i would plug but um
because it's attached to everything
don't follow him save the people and
donate to wells
i would accept the teeth um we're going
to have all his links in the description
box thank you guys so much for watching
we'll see you guys next week we'll see
you again soon hopefully yeah you don't
get weirded out by the teeth
i'm just waiting to see if my mom's
gonna listen to this
sorry mom's having sorry mom don't tell
her about it yeah but how do i purposely
watch she's gonna see that i promote it
oh true all right hi mom
make sure you guys uh give us a like
subscribe to us and give us five stars
on itunes we need it
we need it we need it desperate thanks
guys